benvenuti solida story
oggi ultimo episodio mi dispiace
tantissimo perché ci siamo divertiti
tantissimo se vuoi farlo è vero scherzi
ma questo purtroppo l'ultimo episodio è
abbiamo finì i suoi scherzi stato
bellissimo ma le sostituzioni temo poi
ridere si era infatti alla fine di
questo video se volete comunque potete
rivedere tutti gli episodi o vedere
quelli che non avete visto o vedere i
vostri preferiti vi lascerò appunto la
casellina per rivivere i momenti più
belli il telemarketing script iniziare
assieme ma oggi purtroppo è
l'ultimissimo episodio voi lasciate
comunque ho un bel mi piace e facciamo
che se questo video raggiunge i 10 mila
ragazze proveremo gli altri giochi
quelli simili ascritti cerchi di tipo
xxxvi stranger oppure i giochi finti di
scary vediamo un po come sono mettetevi
comodi prendete i pop corn rino scherzo
e lo stesso uno scherzo tema nata
all'inizio se non avete visto gli altri
in cui le facciamo esplodere l'albero di
natale andate a vederli poi che si
chiama sporting milioni quindi sono
saranno gli artisti e volevo chiederti p
un anno sberluccicante tra capodanno e
già per per i teaser assicuriamoci che
scheri teacher
arrivi al nuovo anno un'esplosione
[Musica]
allora vi traduco tutto ha detto li
stava guardando i fuochi d'artificio
fiori e adesso furti inesperti rispetto
a lei che lei ha un fuoco d'artificio lo
spiegate le carte sembra una navetta
spaziale quando servirà col fuoco
d'artificio loderà tutta la casa
e sanno cosa li aspetta e cioè il suo
fuoco d'artificio gigante ma c'è scritto
che voi dobbiamo dobbiamo farla volare
sono sicura che sarà troppo troppo
troppo divertente questo scherzo perché
se dobbiamo farla volare in aria già è
troppo divertente quello stesso in cui
l'abbiamo gonfiata altre gare e lei si
credeva una modella miss universo allora
vita e che stai cercando per farla
volare insieme al fuoco d'artificio
vedendo che colazione alle varie stanze
magari riusciamo a trovare qualcosa di
interessante nevicando
e proprio tema natalizio adesso
creditizie che beve lei al piano di
sopra
eccolo qui wow è davvero enorme cina
qatar e cerchiamo qualcosa da attaccare
al food per tipi ancora girovagando al
piano di sopra
ma questo qualcosa di interessante una
corda prima non c'era la cuore dell'uomo
neanche la fao è la corda e per
attaccarlo buche d'artificio mano che si
è però troppo divertente si dice farla
volare con alinghi d'artificio fatto il
nodo c'è scritto assicurati che non si
accorge della trappola che forse qui
allora serve questa lista fa con una
tazza di tè per fortuna freddo corsetta
uscendo lei perché la cucina è vicina ai
comprendo la trappola con coperta
proprio scappiamo scappiamo prima che
arriva lì sta già uscendo dio giusto in
tempo abbiamo fatto di vista in tempo
perché lei appena uscita
bellissima bellissimo noi dietro che la
stava guardando
dobbiamo farle uno scherzo manomettendo
i suoi strumenti musicali
scusi lei ma non suoneranno i can't era
quella e dice credimi farai un favore al
mondo e lo voglio sentire cantare the
singles arengo in stava guardando la tv
e adesso la sia una competizione
musicale qui sicuramente vincerò lei è
sempre sempre contini dove era scritto
di trovare qualcosa per farle esplodere
gli strumenti musicali
quindi sicuramente avremo trovare o la
dinamite o non lo so non vale se la
stanza delle tornata a posare da dati
nomi subito abbiamo trovato la dinamite
nella stanza delle torture che abbiamo
la dinamite da mettere degli strumenti
musicali come facciamo però metterla
dentro gli strumenti anni fa ci vuole
qualcosa per fortuna non era accesa da
lei non deve neanche accordo abbiamo
anche trovato il cacciavite anzi ce ne
sono due prenderli tutti e due
casomai ci serve sì in quale dovremo
metterli per la batteria ha smontato
scappa dalla finestra ok si segue ultima
idea
dobbiamo rifare tutto daccapo perché
l'isola dove bruciandole era troppo
pericoloso stare davvero che daisy
potente premi
lo scherzo è cambiato adesso lavorano
non c'è mai successo
quindi vuol dire che a volte quando
fallisce gli scherzi di scherzi cambiano
o magari quello allora degli strumenti
che esplodono lo riproviamo nel canale
digitale andate poi iscrivermi se non
siete iscritti è cambiato lei augurato
il giornale c'era scritto che c'è una
competizione di canto e che lei
sicuramente lo vincerà e quindi c'è
scritto di fare qualcosa per darle un
cheddar l'elastico da quindi penso che
ora dovremo manomettere il microfono
invece de invece degli strumenti
musicali interessante vediamo un po di
questa volta prendiamo la colla da qui
la colla pensi che si può servire nel
1900 quando messi
eccoci se dobbiamo separare l'altro
l'avevo trovata qui la dinamite ma c'è
qualcosa di qualcosa di nero
quel casino che palalido visita per fare
la serata come si chiama sbrighiamoci a
lei e quali può attento richiamo nella
stanza della musica elettori dall amore
profano
eccola la stanza delle nazioni unite sta
sì sì sì sì sì allora mettiamo questo
c'è scritto assicurati che lei non si
possa staccare la microfono bravissimo
che il prezzo la con da non avere le
mani attaccate
questa volta però salto subito fuori
così non mi preme che stiamo scendendo
per lui li questa volta la cosa
funzionerà
l'ultimo scherzo che ri teacher sta
pensando di diventare una buona
samaritana velocissimo questo processo
al via
[Musica]
allora che cosa ha detto praticamente
script inserirà il computer e stava
ordinanza non fate ridere ma
praticamente abbiamo usato i gas
avete visto che all'inizio degli scherzi
ti fa scegliere se vuoi usare un gas per
farla ridere o per farla ballare o poi
ce n'è anche un altro
la prima volta che notiamo dobbiamo
farlo più spesso
praticamente comunque seri tizio nel
computer sta ordinando degli strumenti
di tortura e adesso che userà contro di
no cattivissima quindi c'è scritto che
dobbiamo rubarle la carta di credito
così compreremo qualcos'altro
passeremo per qualcos'altro ha detto che
il miglior chef del mondo ma sta facendo
un caffè mese siamo rubarle la carta
dobbiamo fare qualcosa tirarne
ok allora abbiamo ricominciato questa
volta abbiamo preso il gas per farla
ballare ma lo useremo quando lei è
vicina così riusciamo a scappare sì
dobbiamo trovare il modo di rubarle la
carta di credito ma come facciamo a
rubarle la borsa dobbiamo cercare
qualcosa
vediamo l'indizio dice di trovare delle
pillole per farla dormire ed i sommi per
il mondo
ecco come facciamo rubargli la e tualità
sempre bevendo il caffè quindi forse
dobbiamo metterle me
bene così visto lì però non abbiamo
ancora i sonniferi da mettere dobbiamo
trovare la sostanza allora adesso
micheli potrebbero essere in camera da
letto si levi sa che spesso la vicina ma
noi possiamo sempre farla ballare lei
sta salendo sua salita su adesso davide
parente da quella parte
aiuto non ho fatto parlare prova mi pare
che ci fosse un modo in disco perfetto
grazie a ha beccate sulla germania
bruton tinaia vederla ballare né troppo
divertente
allora mi è arrivata la sostanza di
siliqua
controlliamo sì mi sembra che questo
modesto anni faro che orami aiutare
superattenti e metterli sonnifero da
qualche papà che mangiamo qualcosa che
bene si seduta si è accomodata nel
divano perfetta allora se non sbaglio
stava vicino da eccola ha detto il mio
caffè sarà freddo testo o che dobbiamo
nascondersi così lei non si vede e
aspettiamo che ne beve il caffè speriamo
che funzioni che si addormenti vediamo
e cosa nota ormai lo possiamo rubarle la
carta non piano piano e questa la carta
6 viso di metterla nel computer a donare
dei soldi al giornale i suoi soliti
brevi del prefetto password prince
sbagliata o no bisogna aspettare
speriamo che non si svegli tu non ti
muovi come facciamo troviamo è stato la
card ce l'abbiamo ancora asi per fortuna
non si è accorta che mi ha mutato la sua
carta di computer mini possiamo
riprovare con le scegliamo noi scelto
clown ed era sbagliata
dovevo aspettare come può essere la
password di schiariti ci riproviamo le
mancano solo due di prove o bis quindi
ap oppure spider serrani quale sarà
delle due foto con bis dai proviamo
allora è spider
ma perché lì che aveva paura dei ragni
delle api anche dei topi anche dei clown
poi vediamo se ci sono ma cosa veloce
qualcosa tre no patcher al hindi
dell'indizio sarà scritto che cosa mi o
spam
cosa mi ha spaventato quando ho aperto
il libro e vi ricordate era uno scherzo
del ragno però hai cliccato mente
abbiamo donato in beneficenza i soldi ti
descrivi già abbiamo donato beneficenza
quanto si arrabbierà dobbiamo ha detto
qualche cosa è successo di tutti i suoi
soldi in beneficenza
mi sono rovinata questo era l'ultimo
scherzo stato di verdi singolo per tutti
gli scritti assieme a voi ma per
rivedendo tutti certi tutti gli episodi
cliccate qui e mai vivo andiamo un
bacione darvi ciao ciao
[Musica]